I'll be talking about how we do global
health research at the University of
Washington at this place called the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation which is real mouthful so we
just call it IH Emmie and first let's
tell you a bit about what we do here at
HMI so it's an independent research
center at the U dub we got core funding
from the Bill Melinda Gates Foundation
about eight years ago so it's a hundred
million dollar grant to start it and we
have right now we're up to almost 250
people a combination of faculty
researchers staff a lot of students as
well and our goal is to provide a
rigorous scientific measurement of all
the world's health problems so it's a
very broad goal but the idea started
that the Gates Foundation and a lot of
other funders like themselves as well as
governments wanted to have a better idea
of where's the best place to spend your
money because where are the problems the
biggest what are the cost of different
things what are they
the efficacies of those things and use
that to help decide what's the most
efficient use of resources in order to
improve the world's health and so I H me
we our role is to help take all the data
that's out there and synthesize it into
a more coherent and complete picture to
make those decisions so the big project
we work on that takes up a lot of the
resources and time at HMA it's called
the global burden of disease and the
goal of this is to make a picture of
what is killing people what is disabling
people one of the major risk factors
across the world so we do it for every
single country we've done it from 1990
through 2015 and for over 300 diseases
which and conditions and injuries which
encompass basically every way a person
could get disabled or die disabled yea
disabled or died and then we do it by
age by sex we attribute those two risk
factors and what we end up with is
something like that picture you see on
the right there that's a tree map that
shows you what is the disease burden in
Daly's this is disability adjusted life
years which is how much like healthy
life is lost due to different conditions
I believe this is for 2013 for the world
so you can see the red over there is the
not is the communicable diseases so
you've got L RI is lower respiratory
infections was there in ammonia's that
kill a lot of children as well as older
adults you have diarrheal diseases which
is also mostly young kids you have HIV
and tuberculosis and malaria down in the
bottom of the green you've got injuries
you can see the biggest portion there is
road traffic injuries but there's also a
lot from violence such as Wars and
disasters and then in the blue we've got
non communicable diseases the largest of
which is ischemic heart disease but we
also have a stroke on there there's a
big cluster in the middle there for all
the different types of cancers and so
the goal is just come up with like what
what is the major cause of disease here
and then we want to look at it globally
as well and see what are the patterns
here so this is if you take the death
rate for 2013 a take the Asiana is rate
you can see that it's just vastly how
different is I scales not showing up
here but it's just much much higher in
sub-saharan Africa than it was just
about anywhere else there are parts of
South Asia that are relatively similar
there and then if we look at the
childhood death rate so that's just
children under five the picture is even
more stark which is that most developed
countries in Western Europe Latin
America and North America have had huge
gains over the past hundred years in
reducing child mortality but still parts
of sub-saharan Africa lagging far behind
and further illustrate the difference
between those countries types of
countries if we look at the Daly's back
and that's the deaths and disabilities
the proportion of them in developed
countries you can see is almost entirely
blue that means that's almost entirely
these non communicable diseases such as
cancers diabetes heart disease where
then if we instead look at it in
developing countries it's this red block
is taking up a substantial portion of
the of the picture now with again those
things like pneumonias and diarrhea
taking up a huge portion of the burden
and these are things that we all know
how to solve it's just figuring out how
to deliver the appropriate resources in
order to do that but as you've seen in
the developed countries we already have
a proven ways to reduce those and in
order to do this we have a collaborator
and collaborator network of over a
thousand people and over a hundred
different countries collecting this
information running statistical models
evaluating the results writing papers on
it so this is not just something of a
universal washing this is really a
global effort so that's the biggest
thing that we do it I to me another one
is called the disease control priorities
and this is a collection of projects
that is trying to assess the costs
effectiveness and access to healthcare
around the world so we want to say how
much does it cost for a certain type of
treatment how effective is that
treatment and where can people get that
or where is it lacking and the idea is
that policymakers can you use that
information to assess where should they
put their limited resources to save
lives and so as you can imagine the goal
is to be able to combine this with the
global burden of disease that
information such that international
donors can decide where they could have
the biggest bang for their buck in terms
of saving lives so that's what hme does
and I'll get a bit into why we use
Python so much there we in the
scientific computing group we've got
over a twenty thousand core Sun grid
engine cluster that we use and now we're
using spark where we've got a thousand
core cluster that we've just started up
and are beginning to transition - we
have over 50,000 input datasets which
fortunately for you are almost all
online and publicly accessible if you go
if you just google G HDX that's the
global health data exchange we've got
the largest collection in the world
from all over the world in terms of
death registry data verbal autopsies
which is where you go to door door to
door and you ask has anyone died here
and what were their symptoms we have a
whole set of information on that which
you can use for some pretty cool machine
learning testing to figure out you know
if you have good classification
algorithms and we have a gold standard
data set for that you can use I mean
then we have lots of our different
models outputs as well as well as
information on costs and really just
about anything you want and it's nice
and labeled and easy for you to get we
produce a lot of data we make over every
time we run the GPD
it produces over 25 terabytes of data
and for some of our new projects that
we're pushing over a petabyte every time
we run them and I'll get a little into
those later and then we have interactive
data visualization so all those graphs I
showed you are actually from an online
tool that you can use to browse our data
set and view it all with little d3
visualizations we made so why don't we
use Python for all that a big part of it
is just that it's free and open source
software as well as most of the packages
and that's great for us because we're a
non-profit we don't have to spend more
on software than necessary but it's much
even it's even more important for our
collaborators we're working with people
all over the world who need access to
our software we produce and it's you
know just having any sort of Department
devoted towards the sciences in these
places is often the stretch so being
able to shell out a few thousand dollars
for Stata or something is kind of out of
the question so that that's a big part
of it also is just the ease of use one
interesting thing about IME is although
oh so much what we do is data science
there's not that many actual trained
statisticians and computer scientists
there we have a lot of epidemiologists
we have a lot of medical doctors and
people who come from the social sciences
who do not necessarily have as much
experience with coding and so something
they can pick up relatively simply is
great and especially with ipython
notebooks that's something we found is
just wonderful for helping them figure
out a workflow for coding rapid
prototyping is a big deal for us we try
out lots and lots of models with all our
different research projects and the fact
that we can just get a package fairly
simply for most of the cutting-edge
statistical techniques out there makes
it really appealing for us as opposed to
waiting for we when we used to the state
of waiting for them to come up come out
with some of these new mixed effects
models or something like that and
waiting years in many cases and
extensibility just that we can keep
adding more and more things to these
modules and sort of pushing boundaries
on new methods and integrating them and
probably the biggest advantage for us
most recently has been the scalability
of Python we're now that we're using
with things like PI SPARC and we're
rewriting a lot of backends for our
stuff in C++ but being able to run it
from Python makes it so that our 20,000
core cluster isn't as busy as it used to
be which is great but we can still run
these gigantic models which I'll talk
about in a bit relatively quickly and
then lastly interoperability we
basically use Python as the glue at hme
in that we have lots and lots of legacy
code in a lot of it in Stata or SPSS or
R or more esoteric things going back to
the fact that kind of metrics
departments used to use state a lot
which then meant the World Bank you
stayed a lot in the mid 90s which meant
the World Health Organisation did which
meant we did and so we have you know 20
year old code that not all of it we've
gotten around to up
but we can still call it from Python or
or load in old data sets that were
created in Stata 20 years ago you know
update those a little bit and then use
the pandas to read in the later versions
so it just has made it so that we can
tie all our stuff together into a single
sometimes rickety but at least a single
framework so I'll talk a little bit
about a couple different kinds of models
and statistical techniques we use it hme
the first of which is gonna be our big
ensemble apply form which we use for
estimating causes of death as you
imagine cause of death is sort of the
the biggest headline number that a lot
of people look at when trying to assess
the state of a country's health or
trying to decide where to spend money
it's I want to save lives which means I
want to prevent people from dying due to
certain things so the goal of code M
which is the cause of death ensemble
model is to figure out what kills who
and where and that's actually a much
harder problem than you might expect
a lot of places don't have any sort of
death certificate system you know in the
US you can just go and request anyone's
edge difficut and find out exactly why
they died though even that relies on the
doctor noting it correctly but at least
there's some information there but in a
lot of countries that just doesn't exist
and we have all sorts of different
survey methods we have little sampling
systems and in a lot of places we just
don't have any information whatsoever so
we want to come up with a complete time
series every country in the world every
cause of death over time by age and sex
you know what's killing people so part
of it is filling in all that and then
the other thing we have to deal with is
there's a huge amount of debate about
what is the best modeling strategy for
this there's you know probably if
there's a hundred experts on it there's
101 different ideas on the best way to
do it and so especially since we have
that huge collaborator network and we
want to be able to integrate everyone's
different ideas in this we've hit upon
sort of a an ensemble strategy to
combine all these different approaches
selectively evaluate them pick which
ones work the best and combine them into
an ensemble that sort of pleases
everyone that their model got a shot at
producing the estimates and if it didn't
perform as well and cross-validation
then that's why it wasn't chosen so they
give you an example here's a schema cart
disease so that's dying of a heart
attack effectively or it's After Effects
in Russia and 65 to 69 year olds so this
is what our data looks like and this is
a place where we have fairly complete
time series and now we want to create a
model of this the standard methods that
we often see is first you just fit some
sort of linear regression you have
different covariance you say we know
what the blood pressure is from
different measurements we know what the
alcohol consumption we know about the
cigarette consumption we know something
about the diet use those to make a
prediction of these levels and that will
often get you something but it's not
necessarily very close so the dots are
the data there and like just a simple
linear regression with covariance as
that blue line and then we use some
methods that take the residual
information there and try to smooth it
over time and space for where we do have
data and get a better picture that
doesn't just look at the covariance but
like what do neighboring countries look
like what do other neighboring age
groups look like and that'll get us
something a little better like this red
line and then finally we can use a
something like GPR Gaussian process
regression which will help you fit where
you do have data make better estimates
and so for that we use PI MC actually
and run that through and we get a
slightly better estimate like that and
then we can tweak with the parameters
and all but after a while we come up
with you know some sort of model like
this that takes all three of those
stages combines them together and gives
you a model that looks like that and
that's just for one set of coherences
outs they say well I think that blood
pressure
diet are the biggest factors here but
someone else might say that I think that
smoking and here's the biggest one and
alcohol is a big one I know that people
say well there's no conclusive effects
on alcohol so we try all these different
models we create a giant ensemble where
we run oftentimes it's thousands of
different types of models through all
those stages and what this is showing
you is each row is a model and then
we've done selective cross-validation
based on what sorts of missingness do we
observe than data and you can and what
happens is as you move across do more
sets of cross-validation you'll find
that you get more and more homogeneity
and the rankings of the models and we
use that to choose what's the best
ensemble so we had written this all in
Stata about I guess was five years ago
now and as you can imagine it was a bit
of a mess making thousands and thousands
of models run from Stata so we rewrote
it recently in Python we were able to
speed the whole thing up by about 40
times so we use stats models for the
first stage regressions we've rewrote
all the space-time smoothing again in
Python and then we use PI MC for the GPR
and so not only they make a lot faster
and made it easy to integrate with a an
online dashboard people can just go and
run these models and these could be
epidemiologists who have no idea what
you know how to write a line of code so
that's been great it's enable us to work
with these collaborators around the
world and get their inputs unlike I
think I think we should use alcohol in
this model or not and get their input
into it while we're doing this we've
created a generic ensemble model
framework that we're hoping can be used
for things besides just our types of
models where the basic idea is you
generate a universe of models you set up
some sort of cross validation scheme run
that through and then
it builds up builds ensembles and
chooses how to wait on some the
different models relative to each other
in an ensemble and produces results so
that's a new thing that we've got we're
still tearing out a few of the things
that are really tied into our computing
cluster but if you have any test cases
for running this or the ensemble model
and would like to work with us on that
we'd love to come up with some more
generic examples of how this could be
used so another big priority area for us
is disease modeling of things that
aren't killing people so non cause of
death and for that we have the the issue
we have is that there's a lot of
different measures of disease is you can
count how many people alive right now
have this disease you can count how many
people got this disease this year you
can count how many days is a average
person have this disease for you can say
how more likely is this person to die if
they have this disease and we have all
these different measures from all sorts
of different sources but they're
actually supposed to be somewhat
internally consistent that is that as
you know you more people get the disease
that's the incidence rate then the
prevalence the total number of people
that have it should go up but as the
case fatality rate that's how much more
likely you are to die if you have a
disease goes up
well the prevalence is going to go down
because a lot of those people that have
the disease are dying off so you need
all these things be internally
consistent but they're measured all
independent of each other with different
samples different methodologies and it
just makes for a real mess but we've you
know gone through and done thousands of
studies through giant literature reviews
and coded all that data in and then we
need to make it internally consistent so
that's where we have this thing called
diz mod which uses PI MC to do a little
meadow regression on these and
the idea is that we take the
epidemiological data as well as some
covariance we've run it through diz mod
and now we have just like we had four
causes of death for every single year
country age sex we have estimates of
these different characteristics of the
disease in the population so if you
haven't seen before here is such a
generic disease model the idea is we
have the number of people who are
susceptible in one box that just anyone
who's in the population who doesn't have
the disease then you have people who
have the condition so once you get the
disease you move into that other box
then if the condition kills you you go
into box D which is that those people
who died from the condition and then you
can also just die for other reasons that
aren't related to the condition and that
happens to both people who have the
condition and those who don't and so
then we have all these transition
probabilities between them and we can
start looking at how these things should
be internally consistent
so what disma does is it applies a
series of differential equations to this
and then it forces some constraints to
make sure they all add up and then
estimates all the different transition
probabilities based on that so there's a
whole book on this coming out from my
colleague AV Flaxman I think it should
be out any day now actually so if you're
interested in this entire book just on
these equations but the general idea is
we have here a bunch of data so on the
x-axis that's age and then on the y-axis
it's top left is the prevalence the top
right is the incidence so prevalence is
the total number case in the population
divided by the population so just a
proportion to have it incidence is the
proportion people who develop at each
year then down the bottom we have the
relative risk that's how much more
likely you are to die if you have it
than if you don't and then we have
duration which we have actually no data
on and these lines are the horizontal
width of a line says what's the age span
measured in that survey so people
measure in different age groups some
people say people who
exactly fifty years old some say 50 to
80 year old someday fifty to fifty-five
year olds so we take in all those
different ones and then the vertical
line is the uncertainty interval on that
so now we want to find a way to make
these all internally consistent which is
where we run diz mod on it and it'll
come up with a nice set of estimates
like this that if you ran those through
the differential equations fit that
formula recently we've also rewritten
all of Dizz mod they used to be all pi
mc2 based now there's a new version we
call disma 80 because it does instead of
just smoothing things over age it does
it across space so looks at every
country simultaneously and it does it
across time so it enforces that these
equations make sense across all those
things the back end itself was rewritten
in C++ using this library called CPP ad
C++ algorithmic differentiation but then
we still use a Python interface and a
web dashboard to run it so that anyone
can use it and all this code is online
at that address if you have any interest
in taking a look at it the next thing
I'll talk about is some of the
forecasting work we're doing and some of
the simulation tools we've built in
order to run that so the idea of the
forecasting project is we want to say
what's the most likely thing to happen
in the future given past trends and
whatever information we have how might
that change so under different scenarios
if smoking goes up if there's a natural
disaster if there's another great global
depression what would we expect to
happen to health in that case what
happens if there's a new HIV vaccine how
would that affect population in 40 years
and the idea behind this is Bill Gates
wants to know where to spend his money
right now to save the most lives in 2040
so what we do is we generate possible
scenarios for every quantity that's in
the global burden of disease and we do
it in
a internally consistent way that the we
capture the correlations between
everything such that in a simulation in
which blood pressure goes up well heart
disease and stroke are gonna go up as
well and that will be tied into whether
sodium consumption went up or not so we
want to simulate all these different
trajectories and based on what they've
done in the past and also their
relationships to each other so to give
you a better idea of what I mean by that
here's an example where we've got for
instance just four quantities where we
want to look at what's the GDP so what's
the income of the country tobacco
consumption total death rate and the
population well the best way for us to
predict the GDP and next year is gonna
be to look at GDP and this year but we
also might want to look at did the
population grow or shrink or maybe it's
more did the percent of the population
that's working age change so as the
population gets older and fewer their
people are working age that's gonna hurt
their economic growth then we might also
want to look at what the tobacco rate
next year is so again
this year's tobacco is a great indicator
of that we also find that as income goes
up that's going to affect your tobacco
some of them get that correlation in
their mortality again last year's
mortality as income goes up your
mortality rate goes down and as tobacco
goes up your mortality goes up and then
population is again driven by last
year's population how many people died
this year and GDP can affect things like
migration or fertility rates and so we
just keep cycling through all these
relationships in order to come up with a
simulation all the way out that captures
all these results and then we do this
tens of thousands of times using draws
from the uncertainty distributions of
the transition parameters between all
these states the correlations between
them are uncertainty on what they look
like in the past and so it comes out to
this gigantic mess of a directed acyclic
graph that we need to evaluate
so how we do that is we start out by
just fitting models for each of those
boxes each of those nodes in that graph
based on various different statistical
methods we've come up with which I
believe every single one of those is in
Python and then we run it through that
simulation and eventually once we do
that with all of the different
uncertainty just based on the number of
floating-point numbers not even really
counting all the indices it's going to
be over a petabyte of data just based on
the size of that simulation so what
we've been doing is using PI spark data
frames for scheduling and running these
and I'll get a bit into how we're
actually doing that in a second and then
eventually we're going to expand this to
doing micro simulations as well which is
we're going to include individuals so
that you can look at their actual
interactions with the healthcare system
as they go about their lives so you can
see how often they go to the doctor how
changing for instance how often do you
screen for colon cancer at the doctor
how is that going to affect death rates
in the future in order to run all this
we've created this tool we don't have a
good name for yet I'm open to
suggestions we just call it the
simulation builder and the idea is to be
able to run those sorts of giant
simulations in a very modular way and a
high-performance way so what we've done
is come up with a really modular gamal
schema you just make a little text file
and you can just create that using PI ml
that says what is each node and what so
that's like a quantity like GDP and then
you say what is it related to and how so
you say that GDP is influenced by
population and then you can say what's
the formula for this and you can just
define this using sympa so you can use
basic mathematical mathematical
expressions and you can also add in
custom functions of your own that
operate on numpy or pandas type data
and run those through as well and then
what the simulation builder does is it
creates the dag from that and determines
a knock in execution path and then when
you want to run it you can if it's small
you can just run it in an empire pandas
and I'll do it all right on your local
machine and if you have something that's
much bigger like we do that won't fit
then you can use PI spark just give it
the dag and it'll figure out how to set
up the rest
so we also build a bunch of little tools
in Python like this is using PI curses
and so you have a little command-line
interface that you can explore your
llamó files for instance so for instance
here we've got we're just looking at GDP
per capita as the first thing the
demographic dividend that's the
proportion of population that works and
GDP and it says the GDP is depending on
all these different model parameters and
if we look at for instance if you would
click a hit enter on GDP per capita it
says well it differs by D is draw from
the uncertainty T is time and locus the
locations to the country and it says how
do I come up with GDP for a draw year
and location GDP per capita vetas well
you just take the GDP in that year drawn
location divided by the population in
that year and location so you that's all
you have to do is give it an expression
like that and it'll figure out the rest
it's it'll figure out that oh that means
I need GDP from the same year and
population from the same year in order
to calculate this and add that into the
dag and so once you run that you can
also have it output graphical
representations of the dag and we're
working and it puts it out in a graph is
format so we're working on trying to
come up some tools to like visualize
that and III make it easier to explore
what all is in your simulation so that's
a cool new tool we're working on we
don't have it all on github yet we're
just again tearing out some examples but
I expect within a week or so it'll be up
there so if you have any interest let me
know and I can
give you the address for that next thing
is what we use to map to optimize these
giant models we're fitting and we've
come up with this little tool we call pi
mb python model builder and we call it
that just because it started out as just
a Python wrapper for something called
template model builder which is just a
C++ library but then itself got wrapped
into an r library so the idea is that we
have these models that have in many
cases thousands of parameters thousands
of random effects that we need to
optimize and a lot of the existing
solutions that are built into our just
don't work so the nice thing about team
B is it uses algorithmic differentiation
with CPP D that module I mentioned
before to really quickly optimize these
models and also does this neat trick of
integrating out any random effects and
optimizing with respect to those so that
it can do it much more quickly so it
will just return a some derivative
information as well as likelihood and
you can just pass this to any
optimization function including the
built in sy PI or our optimizer
functions so version 1 it actually uses
our PI 2 runs an embedded instance of R
which itself is running a bunch of C++
modules kind of creaky it works but it's
a little bit more overhead than we'd
like so we're working now on using
scythe on to try to wrap up some of
those functions from this mod 80 which
itself is based on CPP ad to turn this
into a much more generalized function so
you can find that on github now again
it's only a version one that's on there
right now but I'm looking to get version
2 going in the next four to six weeks so
just a little case study of how this
works is there's this mortality
forecasting software out of a Gary Kings
group at Harvard that's widely used for
trying to predict mortality rates and
it's so this your cast package is
written in R and uses a Gibbs sampler
and it just takes forever to run its it
produces great results because it won't
get in the model specification over
there but it allows you to put all sorts
of priors on your model that really help
give good fits but it's just tragically
slow with that get simpler and often
doesn't converge at all we rewrote it in
PI and B got over a thousand times speed
up and we're able to add in a lot more
different interaction terms and just
make the whole model more complex and
fit for multiple countries at the same
time for instance that's the last thing
I'll show you is just we made it so much
faster this is a real-time ipython
widget that lets us run the entire model
in about a second and update a plot so
we can select some of the prior
parameters in it and really actually get
a feel for how the model works which is
something whereas with the r version it
took at least half an hour to run and
some cases several days to run so it's
really just improved our workflow and
ability to fit these cool models that we
think will hopefully lead to results
that that help make better health policy
decisions so if you've got any questions
about any of this or if I went too fast
you missing links just hit me up via
email or let me know after this also
I'll just give a quick plug I just
posted a really cool job description
yesterday to work on some of that PI
spark forecasting work so it's there if
you have any interests on working that
with on that with us okay thanks
which one was that in ah this one yeah
so that sorry I skimmed through that but
it's the color there shows the rank of
the model and then the rows are sorted
based on if you ran 25 different cross
validations how what would their rank be
so in the last column aside from the
in-sample column that just shows you
that fitting your model based on in
sample fit is not a great way to
actually come up with what's the best
out-of-sample hole but in the last one
it's a smooth gradation between green
and red but if you look in the earlier
columns you see that there's a lot of
mixing there which means that if you
only do one or two cross-validation runs
it'll pick a model that doesn't actually
work that well yes
yeah so we we model a lot of outcomes of
violence yes so under the injury section
we have both deaths resulting from
homicide suicide wars and then we also
have a lot of injuries that we look at
disability resulting from them over time
and then we have risk factors for things
like intimate partner violence and
things like that as well
so the question is how we deal with all
the different code where we're producing
and try to systematize that we're
working on making a better system for
that it's difficult largely because we
we come from a very much of research
like epidemiologist perspective most of
us so we're trying to get more and more
systematic about that sort of thing so
we have an internal git repository
system and we're slowly forcing people
to use it and sort of the carrot the
stick approach is that if you want to
run stuff on the big computing cluster
we're starting to say well you have to
have it checked in to get you can't just
throw any code on there and then we're
implementing some code review around
that as well the questions about GPUs
and whether we've use them we've looked
into it a bit we're thinking of it for
some of these micro simulation studies
where we need to have lots of
individuals that we simulate over time
and they can all be independent of each
other so I think it could be very useful
for that the issue with some of the big
other simulations I showed is that they
just have so much data that GPU Ram is
the limiting factor
yes the question who is the consumers
for all this
yeah the Gates Foundation is the biggest
one and the one who fund most of it but
that's starting to change where we're
working a lot with countries themselves
we're working with NGOs that focus on
particular diseases or countries and
we're seeing a lot of uptake just
basically anyone who holds the purse
strings for health money is kind of
interested in this work so the size is
we typically have about 500 different
diseases and 30 20 age groups we do it
over 70 years for 50 risk factors and we
look at about five different ways of
measuring the outcomes and then we do
about 50,000 draws from the uncertainty
estimation so it comes out to a little
over a petabyte of storage for that we
try to work on some short-term things
it's a little bit harder because we as
an organization we require grants to
fund these things and it's hard to get a
quick turnaround those but we actually
just got a grant for some Ebola work
right now